he's a friend of the program and I'm
thrilled to call him a friend he's one
of the best in the business and became
the second tight end with multiple one
thought one thousand yard seasons in his
first three seasons the only other one
is in the Pro Football Hall of Fame and
Kellen Winslow he is the man who helps
the San Francisco 49ers offensive engine
go he's George Kittel how are you George
you know what after that I introduction
I'm pretty great right now thanks for
that one you know I'm pumping you for
the Heisman you know you know what tight
end should win the Heisman Trophy one
year George you know I mean if you're
gonna create your own holiday we should
just go ahead and do the damn thing
right though I'm with you on that we'll
get a promotional thing going next year
how much that was so cool when you did
that for NFL the grind the show I do on
epics it was the tight end the national
tight ends day weekend where you were
hanging out with Favre Favre was a
correspondent we send your way what is
that like for you George oh I was born
and raised in Madison Wisconsin for a
little bit of my childhood and so I grew
up like going to badger games I grew up
going to Green Bay you know the museum
all this stuff up there so I grew up
kind of a Packers fan like early on so
Brett Favre was stuffing pretty fun for
me to be able to meet and have a
conversation with yeah and then you know
you I think you got him a spike a ball
or something like that yeah I got I
gotta throw Gronk spike out their
financial tightening today man is that
gonna stick you think national toy in
today what do you think George did the
NFL is fully behind it you know you know
I'm I'm really for it you know just you
know tight ends getting recognition one
small and I really appreciate and know
this it's just calling on Titans all
over the league to you know produce on
one day together so I'm looking forward
to another one there you go man you know
part of me is a little jealous I've been
trying to get that for punters for years
nobody pays attention so say yeah ya
know Pat's been trying that too for a
long time he hasn't gone it yet yeah
someday
McAfee for the brand so what's going
through your mind right now
you got a bye week you're the 1 seed in
the NFC playoffs what what what in the
world is your mindset like before what
could be one of the most magical rods of
your playing career George yeah that's a
good way to put it I would agree with
you there
almost I'd say you know it's so focus
you know ok I think most the team came
in yesterday we had a you know day off
and most
came in anyways and you know just
treated like it was a normal game week
again which you know it's just kind of
fun to see that focus and that intensity
from her guys and you know we have a
nice day today and I didn't get a couple
of more days off but I'm just you know
looking forward to recovery and I'm
looking forward to playing more football
what was it like the last minute for you
on Sunday Night Football what was that
like restful slightly but you know I it
was incredible you know that's the
atmosphere that you want to play
football in you know then create a great
crowd and loud atmosphere against the
top opponent I mean that's what football
you know that's what makes you a
football player so I absolutely loved
the whole thing and that last moment was
definitely stressful but in our defense
you did what they had to do and you know
eight stops from the 12 yard line is
pretty impressive it's been I mean the
whole season has been unreal George what
clicked let's just start with that what
clicked for the 49ers this year in your
mind I mean my opinion I think that our
team is kind of grew up a little bit
with the last two years we're definitely
really young with a lot of guys knew
their offense um and defense but you
know this definitely this year on
offense like we said guys are familiar
with what they're doing and our rookies
stepped up and they grew up quick and
you know like debo and he just made
plays right away and I think everyone
just you know was doing their job but we
made plays and we had fun playing
football and and we do a lot of you know
a lot of the hard work the gritty work
all the time and it's just I finally you
know paid off this year which is so much
fun yeah you mentioned debo you got a
you got a Samuel you got a Samuels that
certainly put together along with
everybody else was there made a
difference but it just seems to me
George would sent with the D Bo and and
moster there's just a ferocity that you
guys have when you have the ball in your
hands and it just seems to me that
whatever Shanahan is cooking up there
you guys are finding the most
devastating angle to run downhill at in
a most physical manner that few teams
can match I wonder what you'd say when
you hear that when you give guys like
Raheem and Breda Tevin and you know Devo
the ball they get downhill so fast
they're on you so fast and also physical
runners that you know it's really
challenging for defense and know with
all the or run schemes we do a lot of
different stuff with motions and sweeps
and stuff like that you know get the
linebackers
look in different directions then we
even throw the speed on top of it you
know it's hard to keep up with that um
and so we're just you know we're running
the ball really well and efficiently and
I'm just you know hopefully we can take
that into the playoffs with us what's a
football conversation with your head
coach like George Kittel he's like a
computer and then we need someone to
translate what he says for us hi he
talks really fast as lunch lines all
over the papers and stuff like that I
mean it all makes sense
but he talks really fast sometimes but
uh you know it's it's really like you're
learning from someone and it's just fun
because it's it's his offense like
learning from him what he wants you to
do on a specific specific plays and
stuff like that it's just really fun to
interact to someone like that and you
can obviously tell he loves the game
she's been doing it can you give me an
example of the mall like an aha moment
that because you've been playing
football for a long time you've been
around some great minds where where
there's one moment you're like wow I
never saw it that way or anything like
that
well I mean like I've had multiple with
coaching in hand but definitely one that
sticks out the most was last year when
we played the Broncos an 85-yard
touchdown and on Wednesday when we
installed it he goes hey as long as you
don't trip and fall you're gonna score
an 80 yard touchdown here seriously and
he goes yeah you're literally gonna
score touch them just don't trip and I
was like all right sick and then I
scored and I was like all right well
that was pretty cool but while you're
running did you think don't trip
oh I saw him on the silent I was like
our goodness I got to make it to the
endzone course not I'm like oh god yeah
so but Mitt run are you thinking he told
me I'm gonna an 80-yard touchdown I'm
actually doing it I mean a do that or in
the release as I like because it was a
play-action I inserted through the line
of scrimmage the backers all stepped up
and I crossed behind them and layers as
soon as I crossed behind him and I got a
safety went the other direction the
officer where I was going I was like oh
I'm wide open I might actually score
right here so yeah I was I had thought
of it right away it was pretty funny
what day because we haven't spoken since
you did this George kid all the 49ers on
the Rich Eisen show play of the year I
think it's Player of the Year not just
because of how how physical it was but
it was the significance of it and the
fact that again that you wind up as a 1
seed and the Saints don't even get a bye
week and what that could possibly mean
for your chances and there is to make it
to the Super Bowl your run on fourth
down to not only keep the drive alive
for you guys but set up Robbie goal
because of how violent it was your your
catch and run after the catch was
amazing that that that set things up
what was it love were you thinking in
the middle of your run what what goes
through your mind as you're doing that
George I mean the whole play
definitely it's I mean it's tagged for
me to get the ball so I just had to make
a choice break in or out I mean all I'll
say you know just you know do it I can
make the play because you know we it's a
play that we ran you know since OTAs ran
for three years and so it's like hey
you've done it a hundred times just do
it again and then the whole run what the
after the catch I mean I mean I think
I've said a couple of times my tight end
coach always tells me like make people
tackle like you don't have to let people
tackle you um and so that's what you
know I think about you know just I'm
gonna make I'm gonna I'm gonna do my
best job and you know not on tackle me
and that's just kind of how it goes and
then I get a face mask about halfway
through that mm I knew that was in
actually 15 so I just try to go as far
as I could without my helmet coming off
and what how does it feel to be the
recipient of an angry run like that was
holy yeah I mean it's always fun to get
doing those on tape it definitely feels
good I'll tell you that much and what's
it like in the meeting room when you
remember when you run through it I mean
coach no coach chamber he loves the
physicality on the tight ends can bring
and so he always and Joe and he enjoys
those when the DBS don't make the
tackles right away removing yourself who
is the best tight end in the league
George oh I think there's great tight
ends all over the league to do a lot of
different stuff I think right now the
guy to chase is Travis Kelce because
he's been doing it for years in a row at
1,000 yards no one's done it before I
mean that's incredible
or he's he tied the record whatever it
was but he's an incredible Titan that
doesn't you know every single year and
no Earth has been incredible I mean you
got tight ends all over the league that
are playing really really good football
and you know I'm just proud to be a part
of that are you gonna spend your bye
week sir what are you gonna do I'm gonna
hang out and get ready for next week
I'll pay that much what do you mean
you're just gonna hang out just chill
out or oh yeah watching the Hangout so
you don't get some good workouts in I'll
stay in shape and watch a lot of
football okay
what bowl games stuff like that oh yeah
I got to keep a close eye on the bull
games you know because those are fun to
watch yours you all see a lot of crazy
stuff in bowl games too that's like my
favorite part about it it's the most
wonderful time of the year is ESPN says
and uh what did you just spat your team
spanked USC George
I mean I was on one yeah no it was
really fun because you had tus you guys
were you know commentating kind of at
the halftime stuff with Reggie you know
that so it was fun to you know hear them
kind of complain the whole time what do
you think about my team against Alabama
what do you think yeah you guys you guys
go out and get it man
no do you root for the Big Ten do you do
that will you route from Michigan
against Alabama
I will yeah and I'm Pro Big Ten I like
watching the Big Ten succeed because I
think it's one of the better it's I
think it's the best conference I'm just
what every single team top-to-bottom I
think it does a pretty good pretty damn
good job so I like watching the Big Ten
I always root for him so what would you
say about a somebody who loves the Big
Ten I mean diehard Big Ten who let's
just say has a radio television
simulcast in a microphone that reaches a
lot of people that just can't bring
himself to root for Ohio State against
Clemson what do you say to the person
like that that is that petty Jorge would
said person be a Michigan fan yes that
would be his Michigan Michigan fan again
not to drop too many hints as a radio
and television simulcast that you're
actually on right now I wouldn't judge
said person I just couldn't do it no I
couldn't do it man you know I did I did
okay just because I was watching the
game at Bolsa and I don't want to upset
him what did he think of the targeting
call what did he think of that he wasn't
the most happy he's got some pretty high
expectations for every single year it's
pretty awesome but yeah he was
disappointed that defensive line is nuts
I mean chase young isn't saying George I
mean they don't even need to circle him
on the screen you know where he is
he's that's a good football player right
there all right man so look you know
enjoy the week
Congrats on upon a big season you know
it's pretty cool to see the field of
genes all fired up people are loud there
I mean that the
is unbelievable man I do love watching
what's what's happened there and that's
a little bit magical there we it's it's
gotten really pretty fun to play there
and our fans are great no home or on the
road they traveled really well to
Seattle too which is really fun okay we
have some great fans hey man look are
you still up for being there for my
40-yard dash in Indianapolis like you
offered Oh weeks yeah I can't wait I
would love to am I going to backpedal
versus your 40 um you can do whatever
you wish George you know I don't wanna
show you up can I hold like okay I want
to like I want to time you at the same
time by the way I would love for you to
tie me how slow is your trigger finger
though George how slow is it it's brutal
all probably looking at my phone you are
hired sir you are hot here for I'm all
about positive reinforcement baby I
appreciate that and I appreciate what
you said about on Twitter the video
about my dad George that meant a lot
when you tweeted that out at me so thank
you really pays you know I'm just glad
that you share the video you know
resonated really a lot with me so just
relationship I have with my dad so I
really appreciate that and uh you know
thanks again for sharing no George you
are the man thanks for calling in have a
great bye week look forward to seeing
you and which damage you can do in the
playoffs we're looking forward to that's
George kettle 49ers tight end at G
kettle 46 on Instagram and Twitter right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 under red TV for free on VR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app